hello everyone and welcome to game seven
of the world chair championship 2021
it's jani palmishi with uh and the
magnus carlsen and it's gonna be very
very interesting to see what direction
the the match now uh takes as magnus won
game six if you guys still haven't seen
it do check it out it's simply an
incredible game uh and it was basically
a position that magnus could play
forever and nipple uh well he always had
a draw but he always had to play that
perfect perfect continuation of moves
and at some point he just didn't that
queen the e6 move pretty much sealed the
deal and magnus was able to uh to win it
but even if uh nipple found the correct
continuation uh if you don't really
understand why you have to move the way
you have to move then you will blunder
at some point and this is what magnus
was able to capitalize on
so uh game six always delivers like i
said and this match uh seems to be no
different so let's see uh what happened
in this one now nipple has the white
pieces and let's see if he's ready to
strike back immediately you know while
the iron is still hot or he will wait
for his chances some other time now i
don't have the photo of the actual
handshake uh if you guys
have seen the handshake do comment on on
what the handshake was like i'm very
much interested in that but here is the
first move uh i don't know who the
gentleman making the first move is uh he
he has some sort of a a bracelet that i
thought that was very interesting having
such a bracelet you know
you know with a suit uh so do share if
you know who that is and you can see
he's going for the e pawn and you can
see that nepo is very very happy that
he's going after the e pawn uh obviously
we will have another rue lopez now it's
either gonna be the anti-martial like
we've seen three times already or
maybe magnus uh oh well magnus is ready
to go for the marshall but if nipple
doesn't play c3 will not be seeing the
marshall so let's see nipple with the
white pieces opens with e4 and magnus
goes e5 so nothing new here uh we've
already seen this three times with
bishop to b5 the real lopez is on the
board a6 morpheus defense bishop to a4
and now knight to f6 we have castles by
nipple
and bishop to e7 we have rooked a1 and
b5 everything the same as in the
previous three games uh bishop to b3
and magnus castles and now uh of course
if you go for c3 then we strike with the
d5 we go for the martial attack but here
we have a4 so not h3 like in the first
game
rather we go for a4 we have already seen
this two times
rook to b8 by magnus going uh
uh grabbing that b file and now we have
a captures on b5a captures and now
usually you can play c3 d3 we've already
mentioned all of this knight to c3 but
nipple ghost for h3 it's sort of a rare
line but again we've seen it in game
five so d6 by magnus and now if you
remember in game five uh we had c3 and
then magnus uh played this b for move
but here after d6 we have d3 by nipple
still this is not a new new idea uh we
have h6 by magnus and now knight to c3
we have rook to e8 and now knight to d5
there is one game that reached this
exact same position uh from 2013 maxine
vashiela grav won a very nice game with
uh the white pieces uh so bishop to f8
a standard real lopezian idea you want
this bishop on f8 and the rook
controlling the e file and now magnus
goes for knight a story nipple goes for
knight captures on f6 and it is now as
of moon 14 that we have a completely new
game so let's see magnus captures uh on
f6 with the queen we have c3 now
and uh knight to e7 the knight as usual
is uh routed over to g6 then you control
f4 uh we have bishop to e3 and now
bishop to e6 opposing the light square
bishop here on b3 and finally nipple
strikes in the center with d4 we have e
captures on d4 c captures on d for
bishop captures and b3 queen captures
and now knight to g6 magnus now opens up
the attack towards the e4 pawn and
nipple plays rook e to c1 uh trying to
trade off the e4 pawn for the c7 pawn
but this would only uh improve white's
pieces if this other rook comes to a7
could be very unpleasant so magnus
instead just pushes c5 he gets rid of
his only weakness basically
uh and now he's ready to capture on e4
uh if nipple allows it so here uh
capturing wouldn't really be all that
impressive if you capture then we see
sort of a trait here captures captures
and now even rook captures an e4 even
better if the bishop captures knight
captures we've traded off everything
both players have a b pawn on the queen
side and it's uh well very very drawish
so instead nipple pushes e5 and now uh
capturing here would be very dangerous
if magnus captures nepal captures on c5
and now he has this very strong pass
pawn of course magnus is not interested
in playing against this so after e5 we
have queen to f5 just getting the queen
out of harm's way and now uh a capture
fist is incoming so be ready for that so
here we have d captures in c5 d captures
on c5 bishop captures and c5 bishop
captures on c5 rook captures on c5
knight captures an e5 knight captures an
e5 rook captures on e5 brook captures on
e5 and queen captures on e5 and
everything disappears from the board now
we have this position a queen and rook
against the queen and rook with both
sides having a
a one pawn on the queen side uh we have
queen to c3 nip offers the queen trade
because you really don't have all that
much to try here captures captures and
now rook the c8 going after the pawn
rook to a5 and now we have captures and
captures and this is now of course a
draw uh but players i believe are not
allowed to agree to a draw before move
40. so here we have rook to c1 check
king h2 rook to c3
we have h for now g6 we have g3 h5 king
to g2 so just you know making some moves
king to g7 we have rook to a5 and now
king to f6 we have rook to b5 uh
repeating king to g7 rook to a5 king to
f6 rook to b5 we have king to g7 rook to
a5 king to f6 and now even rook to a6
king g7 rook a7 and he was in this
position on mu 41 that nipple and magnus
agreed to a draw uh so we will not be
seeing any any uh blood shed in game
seven of this world championship match
uh but it's kind of to be expected
because nepal didn't wanna you know go
for anything crazy right after the loss
because then if you overextend you lose
two games in a row then even
psychologically it will be almost
impossible to come back in this match
but not only that they really played a
lot yesterday they had to had to rest
and maybe they didn't have all that much
time to prepare something special
so it doesn't seem that nepo is having
all that much success with the rue lopez
magnus has uh
a a lot of a lot of success
in this particular line of defending uh
against uh
well both the h3 and the a for
anti-martial so
i think if we see one more uh
anti-marshal and then maybe one more
anti-martial then i don't think nepal
will have any other choice uh other than
to go for the actual martial attack and
that's what this world chess
championship could be about so if we see
all draws until the last time nepo has
the white pieces i'm sure we will
probably see the marshall attack as you
know there's there's nothing else to try
and mar imagine if he actually wins this
uh that would make marshall very happy
even though he didn't uh you know uh use
the weapon as intended to defeat
capoblanca uh you know it it would make
him very happy if nepal was able to uh
the the bonds back in the world's
championship match uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it uh game
eight uh in coming as soon as it's
played um
of course a rest day is is first then we
continue on december 7th uh i would like
to
congratulate congratulations for your
graduation edon uh happy birthday
andreas fred ackerman vladimir and
daniel heffels for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the world
chess championship until it ends thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day